and now as emily was just saying of
course today is
remembering sunday and the covert
restrictions mean that many won't be
able to mark this most important day in
the way that they would you
usually would and would certainly want
to but of course it's still
a time to reflect on the immense
sacrifice of one generation
to mark the occasion we had an interview
this week with the chief of the defense
staff senate carter i was busy with our
u.s election coverage so my
top colleague debra haynes our foreign
affairs editor went along to speak
to the head of the british armed forces
it's a unique time the country
under lock down an economic crisis that
we haven't known for for generations
like why should
people care about remembrance well i
think the most important thing about it
is that it's about honouring those who
gave their lives
in the service of our country and of
course they did that to protect our way
of life and our freedom
and i think it would be very dangerous
if we forgot that not least i think
because
you know we need to hang on to that idea
of democracy
why is that dangerous if we don't
remember the sacrifice of the past
well because i think that what we will
also forget is the true horror of war
and if you forget about the horror of
war then the great risk i think is that
people might think that going to war is
a reasonable thing to do
now in certain circumstances that might
be the case but of course you need to
understand what you're taking on when
you do it
because it's always visceral it's always
violent it's always brutal
and ultimately it leads to people having
to sacrifice their sacrifice their lives
in the in the cause and that's a you
know quite a thing for people to do
so we need to remember that we need to
learn from it and we need to make sure
that
people only take us to war when they
absolutely have to and like looking at
history
history tells us that economic crises
lead to security crises how worried are
you that the
global economic crisis brought on by
coronavirus
could lead to new security threats
potentially even war
yes i mean i think you know we're living
at a moment in time where the world is a
very uncertain
and anxious place and of course the
dynamic of
global competition uh is a feature of
our lives as well
and i think the real risk we have with
quite a lot of the regional conflicts
that are going on at the moment
is you could see escalation lead to
miscalculation
and that's the thing i think we have to
guard against miscalculation can you
just spell that out in
easy language what does that mean so
what that means is is that the
protagonists either because they don't
realize the implications of their
actions
lead to an escalation which means that
more people perhaps get involved more
weaponry gets involved
and before you can contain it it leads
to
the sides ending up in a full-blown war
and if that happens as we saw in the
last
century i mean we have to in the history
might not repeat itself it has a rhythm
and if you look back at the last century
before both world wars i think it was
unarguable that there was escalation
that led to the miscalculation which
ultimately led to
war at a scale we would hopefully never
see again so are you saying that's a
real threat that there could be another
world war i'm saying it's a risk
and i think we need to be conscious of
those risks and that's why remembrance
matters because
if you look back at history hopefully
you learn from their experience and you
make sure that you're very cautious
about how you manage the sorts of
regional conflicts that we see
playing out in the world today um
looking at coronavirus
uh the first time around it seemed that
the government was kind of almost
wary reluctant to use the military and
the armed forces being involved on the
streets may be a sign that
things aren't going so well was that
frustrating for you
and do you think that this time around
in the second wave
we'll see more even more military
presence obviously the military have
already done a lot
um i don't think the government was in
any way reluctant to use the armed
forces
i think it's always a question about
what the armed forces can do
and of course over the last 10 years
we've seen a lot of times that the armed
forces have been deployed
in support of the civil authority
whether it was the 2012
olympics which you'll remember but
equally there's been a lot of bad
weather
over the course of the last 10 years and
often we're deployed in support of
flooding now i don't think the
government has ever felt that it was
inappropriate to do
that or indeed it showed that things
have gone wrong and the answer is that
the armed forces are there to provide
that level of national resilience so i
didn't think there was any
reluctance to use the armed forces i
think like all these things it's about
working out
how you can use the armed forces in the
most effective way
and actually i've been hugely proud of
what we've contributed
you know we've done it behind the scenes
we've been supporting
the health workers on the front line and
we've applied some quite imaginative
ideas to how we can help them
and i think what we did with
constructing the nightingale hospitals
which
sadly look like they'll be back in use
again what we've done in terms of some
quite imaginative work
in the testing program and indeed what
we did to deliver
ppe the personal protection equipment at
scale
all of that i think are indications of
how the armed forces can
turn their hands to most things when
they're required to as part of that
national resilience
and we've been told by the defense
secretary that there are seven and a
half thousand
military personnel um ready as part of
this winter defense force
can you imagine all of them potentially
having to be used
over the coming months well of course we
always aim off for contingencies
um and um we're aiming off for all sorts
of things that might happen this winter
not least
bad weather so the answer is i don't
know um but we are prepared for whatever
eventuality might happen
and of course we're about to deploy um
2000 or so
people up to liverpool to take part in
this multi-testing
pilot scheme that's underway and i
suspect that if that works successfully
we might find that there are other areas
where we need to help in a similar sort
of fashion
so test and trace it's it's a key
fundamentally a big logistical challenge
isn't that exactly what the armed forces
are designed to be able to achieve
wouldn't it make much more sense just to
give that whole
piece of important work to the military
and let them run the command and control
and run that test and trace program
well i mean it is an option but i think
at the moment we should um
have confidence in the testing system i
mean when you think back in may
we were only able to do 10 000 tests a
day
we're now doing 500 000 tests a day and
that is on a very steep
path at the moment and i think actually
the testing thing has been a really
impressive effort
the trace thing is another matter
altogether and i'm not sure that that's
necessarily
a military task of course we'll step up
to the plate if we're invited to do it
but i've got confidence in the system at
the moment but you say it's an option
like have you ever offered the military
up to be this
solution to help the country deal with
the challenge of
of having an effective testing program i
think we've always been
clear in defense that we're available
and the government's always known we are
um ultimately you want sustainable
solutions and what we must never lose
sight of of course is that our principal
purpose is to
deter the country's enemies and we do
that on an ongoing basis
and whilst it is entirely appropriate
for us to help in times of crisis
what the government really needs are
sustainable solutions so that we're
available to do what
we should be doing on a normal daily
basis well that leads us on very nicely
to
the integrated review obviously there's
this big review going on that's been
going on for months now of
of uk defense foreign uh development
policy um for you uh how
important or how hopeful are you that
that defense will be given
um a a multi-year settlement from the
treasury even though obviously we've
heard from the treasury that
most of the departments will be only
getting a one-year budget i mean the
answer is i i don't know
um at the moment there are negotiations
going on in a very constructive way
we've absolutely we absolutely
understand the challenge the country has
and we've talked in this interview about
the
very difficult fiscal situation and of
course from the
treasury's perspective you know you need
to be sure of your fiscal assumptions
before you're clear about whatever the
future might hold and therefore what a
long-term settlement might look like
but clearly from our perspective we're
going to argue for something like that
because
we need long-term investment because
long-term investment gives us the
opportunity to have confidence in
modernisation
you know modernization essentially means
that you're going to park some
capabilities that are perhaps from the
industrial age
and want to look forward to some of the
capabilities you need for an information
age
and having the confidence to do that of
course means you need confidence in your
long-term investment i mean on that
front
should the country be ready when they
look at their military um to have
a very different looking armed forces
going forwards
they're actually fixating on the size of
the armed forces
on this 82 000 strong army is actually
the wrong metric and what you should be
looking
at is capability increased use of
autonomous weapons
increased use of cyber of space to be
able to have maximum effect
are we going to see a smaller armed
forces but are more powerful armed
forces
um i think you're going to see an armed
forces that's designed for
the 2030s i mean you won't get there
overnight but that's the direction of
travel
and we think that a armed force is
designed for then is going to be one
that
is organized through the prism of the
domains of land are maritime but also
cyber and space because it's the way
that you integrate all of those domains
together
these days and certainly into the future
that gives you your disruptive edge
so i think you'll see armed forces that
are designed to do that and i think that
absolutely means that
we will have all manner of different
people employed because those domains
require different skill sets
and we will absolutely avail ourselves
of autonomous platforms
and robotics wherever we can but we
don't yet know and nobody can predict
the future
quite what mix of technologies will be
necessary
to be able to achieve that and that's
why returning to
the lost art of experimentation
something that perhaps we haven't done
constructively since the 20 the 1930s is
something that we'll absolutely have to
do
but can you spell that out does that
mean like the 82 000 figure is going to
go and it's not going to it's going to
be a smaller
actual military no i can't spell that
out not least because decisions haven't
been taken
but what i'm hinting at is that we need
to be thinking about how we measure
effect in a different way
i mean i suspect we could have an army
of 120 000 at which
30 000 might be robots who knows but the
answer is we need to open our minds
to perhaps numbers not determining what
we should be doing but rather the effect
that we can achieve
is really what we should be looking for
the uk threat level has risen we've seen
terror attacks
in austria and in france is this a sign
of a
resurgent islamic state a resurgent
islamist extremist threat that could
play out here in the uk too
i mean the answer is i don't know and of
course our thoughts are absolutely with
um
those who've been affected in france and
of course in austria um
the plain fact is that the challenge of
um daish
of the islamic state has not gone away
and we have forces deployed in parts of
the world at the moment which are
dealing with that particular challenge
uh it's a clear and present threat
and it's one that we should all be alert
to the overseas operations bill
um is obviously passing through
parliament at the moment
and you'll you'll be fully aware of the
concerns that have been raised
and particularly by by labor and also by
a number of conservative mps that this
is giving um a carte blanche to the uk
armed forces
to commit war crimes potentially torture
what do you say to that i mean my
starting point would always be
that if uh our forces um
do not behave in line with our values
and standards and the laws of war
on the ground then they should be
properly held to account for that
but i would also say that we have been
struggling with that
vexatious claims from the campaigns of
iraq and afghanistan over the last
decade or two and that is something
which i can't condone
because ultimately that threatens the
way in which our leaders
on the ground are prepared to seize
those fleeting opportunities that you
need to win on a battlefield
so the trick is to maintain the moral
high ground which is fundamental to us
we must never lose that
and therefore we must be held to account
whilst at the same time trying to make
sure that
vexatious claims don't pursue us okay
thank you very much